chez le créateur de mode torontois mike
carter les couleurs et les formes
fluides sont la marque de fabrique son
entreprise le hommos trano propose des
collections de vêtements non genre et
je voulais que les personnes non binaire
puisse avoir une garde-robe qui leur
ressemble
au delà des idées préconçues qui décide
ce que les hommes et les femmes doivent
chaque emporté
pour des personnes non binaire comme
danny kass et ses barrières entre les
genres est important
mais aussi éviter des regards parfois
blessant
20 ans l'enseignant s'est habillé comme
un homme à contrecoeur c'est la pandémie
qui lui a donné le coup de pouce pour
oser porter les vêtements reflétant son
identité
ici se réjouit de voir que de plus en
plus de créateurs confectionne des
collections nom jean riffaud ces
changements de mentalités se remarque
aussi chez les étudiants en design de la
mode qu'il ya une rupture rupture entre
un monde qui est davantage
accès par ses ballard
l'ancienne société en cette société
bourgeoise qui mine de rien de continuer
encore à exister et cette nouvelle
génération qui tente mine de rien de
justement de faire bouger les choses de
créer finalement une société qui leur
ressemblent d'avant après tout dit il la
mode est un miroir de sa société et le
vêtement en est l'un des reflets ici
camif high rise and radio canada toronto